you're setting up your brand and you
need to make sure it reaches the right
audience and provide the best results
there's really only one place to turn to
it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on Google and so today
we're gonna talk about how to advertise
on Google so thank you for joining my
name is Rob Sanders I'm with simply
learn and we're gonna talk about all
things Google when it comes to
advertising so thanks for joining and
let's get right to it and talk about
Google Ads and its effect with
advertising so we're gonna start out
with what are Google ads well Google ads
used to be called Google Adwords and
it's been around good while almost 20
years now so really Google has grown at
a really rapid pace it's become one of
Google's main sources of revenue you
could say probably in the 90 percentile
of its revenue comes from Google Ads and
when we say Google ads we mean people
who pay for advertising on Google com
so Google ads really what it does is it
provides services that fall into the
category of PPC which stands for
pay-per-click you may also may hear
Google ads or PPC referred to as cost
per click or CPC or sponsored search
really when it comes down to it's a
model so when you advertise in
google.com and somebody clicks on your
ad basically you're paying Google for
they click okay so it's just really a
business model where an advertiser pays
Google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay Google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
I want to advertise my business I can go
to Google ads and say Google Place my ad
on google.com and then my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as
I pay Google a fee so Google ads it's
just an online advertising platform
developed by Google with which
advertisers can pay to display ads they
can offer up their services there's
video involved there's obviously
Mobile's involved so you got all the
necessary devices and platforms
available in Google's ecosystem so for
example if i go to google search even if
i type in you know what is google ads
here i can see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what are google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from YouTube you
got a knowledge graph here you got
featured snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're gonna focus on today we're
gonna talk about sponsored search so you
can see here for this particular keyword
query that I typed in what our Google
Ads really to sponsored search or
pay-per-click ads appeared now if I
Cap'n to click on any one of these two
and go to that particular advertisements
website they're gonna pay Google a
specific cost per click so that's how it
looks on google.com it really depends on
your query and what ads show up but the
great thing about your Google ads is
they make it known for the user who's
doing the search query what the ad is so
here I can easily pick out what's an ad
a sponsored search or pay-per-click ad
and what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an advertiser
advertising on Google com I'm gonna be
able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo there ad
it's letting the end-user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have that little Add box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's
paid search ad now why do we want to
advertise on Google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so what I mean by that is you
know search is really a great place to
advertise because you're meeting the
consumer halfway meaning somebody's
typing something in and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so Google Ads advertises your
product or service to the relevant
audience to ensure the users perform the
action required to them so it's really a
great way to get quality audience to
your website because if somebody types
in something and you happen to offer
what they're looking for
basically your ads gonna show up
somebody clicks on it you pay Google for
the click and you get quality traffic in
return so the other great benefit to
being on Google ads is increases brand
awareness so it's a great way to get
your product and brand out there Google
has a vast network also known as the
Display Network but even on google.com
the search network itself the search
engine itself means of people use it
every day fact here in the United States
it's been said or studied that you know
people over the age of 18 you search at
least once a day at least once a day
here in the United States so you can
figure that's millions and millions of
people so it's a great way to get your
brand in front of a large captive
audience okay so top of mind awareness
refers to a brand a product being the
first one that comes to a customers mind
when thinking about a particular
industry or category so it really does
provide top of mind awareness another
benefit to being on Google Ads is
retargeting so when we say the word
retargeting in marketing that means you
know showing our ad to somebody who's
already been to our website so we can
use Google's Display Network or we can
run remarketing lists for search ads
right on google.com to ensure that we're
targeting those folks who have already
been to our website and have not
performed a function that we want them
to perform such as converting or buying
something or downloading something or
subscribing to a news
or visiting a certain page okay so if
somebody doesn't do what we want them to
do it's okay maybe they aren't ready to
commit to our product or service and
that's why Google Offers up retargeting
so it allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with our product they're gonna
be familiar with the website because
they've been there and so we can offer
up a very unique specific ad to that
audience so that's a really good benefit
to being on Google ads so some other
benefits here increased intelligence so
you know we can certainly get data about
who is coming to our audience so we can
look at what device what you know
browser etc so we can really gain some
information about who's coming to the
website we could certainly measure our
performance so with Google
we're paint cost-per-click and so based
on that model you know we can certainly
measure what keywords what ads are
generating traffic to the website and
how much we're paying for that okay and
if that traffic turns out to be lead we
can measure that against that specific
keyword or ad or campaign so we could
certainly measure our performance all
that we down the keyword level and can
we can measure up against how many
conversions or what we're paying for
those conversions so Google Ads is a
very highly quantitative approach to
advertising because there's a lot of
numbers involved and you're constantly
collecting information about your
advertising on google.com and it's
Network and another benefit really it's
as high flexibility so Google Ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
Google Ads
has very flexible options in terms of
advertising and we're going to talk
about some of those as we move along
here today so another big benefit here
and this is what I always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider Google
Ads because as we shown here in our
example if I go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on Google Ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you could bid on it
so it definitely is a good option if
you're not ranking for a particular
keyword organically so it serves as
almost an option I always say that you
know search is like a fruit bowl okay
you have apples and oranges in that
fruit bowl while the orange is organic
search and the Apple is paid search
they're different approaches but they
share the same fruit bowl the same real
estate so you can really really help
yourself by using Google Ads to
complement what you're doing organically
so if you're not ranked organically for
keyword you can certainly use Google Ads
if you are ranked for specific keywords
and it's a highly competitive industry
then you can use Google Ads to help you
leverage the amount of clicks you get
from that ad so it's okay to be
organically listed and have a paid
search listing at the same time so if we
go back to our example here we could see
word stream com has a paid ad and here
we can see just two spots below
organically they're showing up with an
organic listing so you could certainly
be in both positions to try and maximize
your clicks so it's definitely a good
strategy to run with Google ads on top
of everything we mentioned in terms of
measurement flexibility Google Ads does
offer a really good incentive to
advertise and let's not lose focus that
again search is really the only medium
in which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for and
when I say halfway meaning your ad is
going to appear for somebody who is
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor or
directions search is there
serve that that person needs there's no
other advertisement platform or another
channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be TV or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's SERP and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the SERPs or also known as organic
search but the great thing is Google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift focus now talk about the various
formats and Google ads on Google search
we have text ads so text ads are the
only ad format on Google search and so
here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one AD so JBL headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
Amazon Diane third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about Google ads with with its text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also gonna contain what we call ad
extensions so here you can see shop by
category in ear headphones on ear
headphones those are all sitelink
extensions meaning they're going to link
to something on your website and so the
purpose of the extension is to help get
the click so the reason why you're
running Google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
two description lines and adding
extensions to your ad I'll help you get
that click yes you're gonna pay Google
for the click but that's the whole
purpose is to generate the click from
search because remember
search is there to respond to somebody's
need or query and so if you get the
click on your ad chances are it's going
to be a highly relevant visitor to your
website so Google Offers up a lot of
opportunity for you to write a lot of
information in your text ad on Google
for Google com so Google also has other
formats and so they also have responsive
display ads so when we say responsive we
mean Google can serve up a specific
image from your website based on what
somebody's looking for based on the page
that they went to
so these ads are responsive they adjust
their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and/or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like Amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let Google do the
heavy lifting why not like Google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows Google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on Google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to Facebook we have a
thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on Facebook versus
Google you have multiple multiple sizes
that you can choose from in terms of
running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if
advertise on Google okay you also have a
promotional ads these ads are used to
drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for uber so
that's another option - if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so Google owns you - so
you can run advertisements video
advertisements on YouTube so they could
be standalone or they can be inserting
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are gonna
look at your ad before actually watching
the actual video they went to YouTube
for so you have a lot of different
options with video advertisements on
YouTube so the other ad format you have
on Google are shopping ads and shopping
ads a really a great way to get your
product in front of the right user so
somebody's looking for shoes or running
shoes it's an opportunity for you to run
shopping ads so you could put that
particular shoe with a description with
the price with your brand name in front
of that user and so with a cost per
click model if you user clicks on your
shopping ad then chances are they're
probably gonna convert because they
could see the product they could see the
price they could see the product name
they can see the brand and so it's an
opportunity for you to really drive
high-quality traffic to your site with
the opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if I go to Google search and I
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here I could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names I could see the
price point if I hover over it I can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews return
policy so if I actually click on this ad
chances are I'm going to buy it
otherwise why would I click on the ad
isn't any
and so that's the great thing about
shopping ads it gives you the advertiser
an opportunity to really get your
products in front of people who are
looking for your product or service and
giving that your listing the price if
they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily be
running shoes it could be anything that
you have to offer a user so running
shopping ads on Google is a good
strategy if you have products okay so
you can showcase these these shopping
ads on Google search by certainly really
giving Google access to your product
inventory connecting in some reviews
connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up Google Shopping ads within Google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if I'm on Google search you know I can
go to shopping or I can go to images and
I'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and I will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on Google search tip those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with Google
you also have call ads so when we say
call ads really call only ads are great
for mobile so when you run
advertisements on Google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number they click on your number they're
actually going to call your business and
Google can track that they can track how
many people click on your number and
even turn that into a conversion for you
so if you have a phone number associated
with your business it's wise to go ahead
and set up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the ad because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so who can track call
as well so keep that in mind if you have
a phone number and you want to associate
that phone number with an ad okay so
let's move over to where is Google
showing your ads I showed you an example
of Google search so we looked at text
ads and we looked at shopping ads on
Google search Network so Google search
Network really allows you to advertise
on Google search so with Google search
if I go back to Google search and I go
to all I typed in running shoes okay
here I can see shopping ads here I can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show at the top and if you're not
at the top then Google will place you at
the bottom so really depends on the
keyword that somebody's query in in
Google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what Google does if I didn't have any
shopping ads here Google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on Google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and I would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember Google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
gonna advertise on Google with the text
ad you wanna make sure you're always at
the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
Google Ads is affiliated with so the
first is Google search okay so let's
focus on Google search and so basically
when we say Google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
Google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com you're
will appear basically below or above the
search results on a Google search so if
somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device Oswal so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
Google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above some featured snippets and
the organic search results
okay so depending on a lot of different
factors again I've mentioned this
throughout the webinar there are a lot
of factors in showing up in the top
position second position third position
and so forth okay if I scroll all the
way to the bottom you may even see ads
down here depend on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we can
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again I can see the
logo ad here okay so I can see simply
learn using three headlines
I can see simply learn using their two
description lines here and I can see
simply learn using some other extensions
with the ad now all of this is geared
towards getting the click so when you're
on Google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the clay
okay so that's the whole idea behind
being on Google search if you're on
Google search you have the opportunity
to be at the very top of the search
result we're in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if I change my search query and
typed in coffee in San Francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different
I'm gonna see local listings here okay
so this is tied to Google my business
not Google ads okay so this is
completely different so don't mix this
up with running ads on Google search so
Google my business is tied to local
listings or Google Maps and again with
desktop which is what I'm showing you
the search result on you're gonna see
likely Google local listings above
organic results okay and if I go back to
my previous query of classes on digital
marketing I'm gonna be able to see paid
search results above local and organic
listings so in other words if you're
running ads ads are going to Trump any
other type of results on Google search
if you can be in positions one through
three now in addition to google.com
Google also has something called Google
search partners so if you set up an
account and you set up a campaign in
Google Ads you have the option to choose
Google search as your network and then
as an alternative or an additional
option you can advertise on Google
search partners sites and so some of
their search partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with Google that's allowing
Google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between YouTube
to Amazon to New York Times let's take a
look at an example
it could even be another search engine
so if I go to say ask.com
and type in classes on digital marketing
it's a completely different search
engine but I can see the same ad for
simply learn so I can see same I could
see a different headline here actually
but I can see the description and I can
see some sitelink extensions and so
notice the ad is still at the top in
this case it's in position one and I can
see multiple companies running
advertisements why because they can see
ad next to it and I could see those over
over organic listings so these
Google search partner listings so you
can opt-in to be on other partner sites
that Google or other sites that Google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of Google search and
that option is display networks so
Display Network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of Google
search and if you're going to advertise
on Google's Display Network you have
more ad formats available to you
including image and including video for
example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the New York Times calm or
WebMD or Marriott com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell Google hey this is the site I want
to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the Display
Network so if you don't want to
advertise on Google search Kait
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're gonna grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect
so you're basically reaching out to a
large number of people on Google's
Display Network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about
so for me the Display Network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the display the Display Network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so retargeting as
we said earlier is really reaching out
to people who have already been to your
website and didn't perform a particular
function that you wanted them to perform
meaning somebody came to your website
from paid search on google.com and they
went to page a
they left so you really wanted them to
go to page B add a product to a shopping
cart and check-out and purchase that
product however if they didn't do that
you can certainly run ads knowing that
they've been to page a and page B and
you can offer up that specific ad to
that person who's been to your website
and so that's what we're targeting
really is all about and you can retarget
on Google's Display Network
so remarketing your product to people
who have previously visited your your
website or even your app allows you to
really get your ad in front of a
qualified audience and so you could take
advantage of analytics so Google's ads
as all the information you need so let's
actually take a look at some of these
options in Google Ads for the Display
Network so if I actually go to Google
Ads and I actually go to display
campaigns I can see I have a lot of
different options available to me so if
I click on keywords for example okay I
can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what Google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
Display Network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
Google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the splake network
you could say hey Google I only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and so based on that
Google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the Display
Network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so Google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if I just choose a particular ad
group now I have specific topics that I
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news
pets and animals and so under each one
of these topics I can get really
specific so if I go under science I can
see subcategories under the topic
science I can see chemistry and physics
and scientific institutions and
equipment so I can really pick and
choose specific topics where I want my
ads to be shown as I mentioned already
you can pick and choose specific
placements okay so if you have a
specific website that you want your ad
to be shown on you can certainly let
Google know you can also advertise on
Gmail you can also advertise on YouTube
so you can really pick and choose where
you want your ads to be shown so you
have all these different options
available to you to me that one of the
best options for advertising on the
Splane Network because when you tell
Google you have a specific audience you
want to target and that audience could
be somebody who went to a specific page
where somebody who went to your website
and didn't convert you can associate
that audience with the campaign and when
you associate that audience with a
campaign you can retarget them with an
ad so the display campaign is very
powerful with Google because you have
all these different options available to
you so with Google ads you can also
determine how well you're reaching your
goals which websites you're running your
ads on which ads are bringing in clicks
and which site gives you maximum value
for the minimum cost so you can see all
that in Google ads so when I actually
pick and choose how I want to target
I can certainly measure that so for
example audiences or demographics for
example if I go back to demographics I
have all this data that Google's
collected on my advertising so I can see
for example by age range based on my
campaign how many clicks how many
impressions impressions or how many
times my ads been seen click-through
rate meaning the rate at which people
see my ad and are clicking on my ad how
much I'm paying per click CPC is cost
per click total cost and conversions how
many conversions am I getting so I could
see all this data available to me in
Google ads so it's a very powerful
platform for measuring performance
let's talk about how you can create a
Google Ad okay so first thing you want
to do is you want to set up your
campaign and you want to align and go
with that campaign just like we talked
with bads related to Facebook you always
want to align a goal with your campaign
just like we talked about there we want
to do the same thing here on Google so
we have a number of different options at
our disposal so when you run a campaign
why are you running the campaign so if
you're in just to drive traffic or
you're trying to generate brand
awareness okay great you can still set
up that campaign you're just going to
choose the Display Network
okay the Display Network allows you to
get your ad out there on millions of
websites so that people can actually see
what your brand product or service is
all about now if you're into direct
response meaning you're in it for sales
and leads then you probably want to
choose potentially Google search
partners as a network okay not display
but Google search and the partner sites
okay on Google search so by choosing
Google search as your network it's
director response so somebody's typing
in a keyword query and you're responding
so that's the whole idea behind Google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose Google search partners okay again
if you're into you know driving brand
awareness our product and brand
consideration then maybe you should
choose to display Network the bottom
line is you need to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign that's the very
most important very first step and most
important step is to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign and once you've
decided that then it's on to setting up
the campaign and in Google you're always
going to have at least one ad group and
what makes up in a group keywords and
ads so ideally when you set up a
campaign
on Google search Network you're going to
choose keywords and those keywords
should be tightly knitted or tightly
themed or in other words be all relevant
to one another in an ad group so that's
what an adverb is keywords that are
relevant to one another okay in that ad
group you're also going to have an ad so
when you choose your keywords you're
gonna write an ad for those keywords so
step three is after you set the ad group
and choose your keywords you're gonna
create an ad so let's take a look at how
about looks in Google Ads
so if I go to Google ads I can see I
already have an account set up I have a
couple campaigns so let's just say I
have this campaign set up here I'm just
gonna call it industrial campaign okay
and if I choose industrial campaign okay
I'm going to then be asked to set up an
ad group now if I set up an ad group
already in that ad group should be
keywords and ads okay so remember when
you set up an ad group you want to
choose your keywords first paying this
keyword should be all related to one
another so for example I could see an ad
group here called fig concentrate well
if I click on this ad group and I look
at the keywords they should all be
related to fig concentrate so here we go
we can see a few keywords in this a
group in fact I have ten of them all
related to fig concentrate so it's very
very important from a quality score
perspective if you remember when we're
talking about qualities for quality
score is based on landing page
experience expected click-through and
the ad relevancy to the keyword so if
you can choose a group and have all your
keywords related to one another like I
do here with fig concentrate then it's
easier to write an ad okay so here I
have ten keywords all related to fig
concentrate so now if I go to ads and
extensions in the Google ads platform we
can see here I already have a couple of
ads going okay so ideally if I wanted to
I can run more than just two ads as a
best practice as a best practice you
want to have at least two ads why
because these two ads are going to be
served
against each other and ideally the whole
idea of running more than one ad is what
Google can do is start serving up the ad
that is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so here I'm
gonna go ahead and add one more at here
okay so if I click on that plus button I
have a bunch of options here I'm gonna
go ahead and choose text ad because I'm
running this campaign on the search
Network and my goal is to get sales not
lead sales so I want sales I want
somebody to click on my ad go to my
website and purchase some fake
concentrate so that's my goal and so if
I'm on the search Network I can only
have text ads so I'm going to choose
text that and once I choose text app
then I have the option now to go through
and create a new ad okay so what Google
actually does is they populate the ad
from previous ads and so this gives me
an opportunity to tweak one of the ads
already have in place so here you can
see I have a final URL and that's the
URL that the traffic is gonna go to when
they click on your ad okay so somebody
clicks on the ad that's the page they're
gonna go to call that the final URL now
I have an option to create up to three
headlines so here I can see headline 1
up to 30 characters I have my brand name
headline - I have something related to
the keyword I'm bidding on so what am I
talking about
they concentrate okay again up to 30
characters now that includes spaces so
if you happen to go over 30 characters
your ads not going to get approved so
here you can see 32 over 30 I'm two
characters over I just get rid of that
the ad is okay so you got to be careful
to stay within the boundaries of the
character limits including spaces so
here I got headline two as big
concentrate now I'm going to write
headline three this is new so this is
recently implemented by Google and I
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are gonna be greater and that's
what we want we're gonna advertise we
want to advertise so that people can see
our ad and click on our ad that's the
whole point isn't it to get people to
click on our app because they're looking
for something that we're offering in
this example fit concentrate so here I
have headline 3 I'm gonna go ahead and
put something in the headline 3 maybe a
promotion let's just say I'm offering up
20% so I can say up to 20% off through
April ma now you see them run into
character counts so I'm just gonna go
ahead and keep it at April so up to 20%
off through April now I can create
another ad and maybe change the headline
to say up to 20% off through May so you
want to take advantage of all three
headlines now notice when I added the
headline here I can see a preview of it
on mobile and I can see a preview of it
on desktop now underneath that I have
what they call the display path so what
Google does is they take your domain in
this case Valley fig calm and you can
basically customize that domain with
what they call a path show you a path
one path to and the whole point of this
is for you to customize it based on the
keywords you were bidding on so I'm
bidding on fig concentrate I'm gonna put
fake concentrate in here now remember
when somebody actually clicks on my ad
they're not gonna go to Valley fig calm
/ fig / concentrate they're gonna go to
the URL up here under final URL so you
want to make sure you put a path in
there ideally what I would do is put in
something related to the keyword I'm
betting on in this case pick concentrate
now I have an opportunity to add a new
description a second description this is
new and I have up to 90 characters so I
can go ahead and add some content so
remember what description - I have up to
90 characters so I'm just gonna go ahead
and borrow some copy from the website if
I'm not actually sure what to write
and so here you can see thick
concentrate is a natural product
containing no preservatives or additives
so that's my second description so now I
can go ahead and save and create
extensions so I'm just gonna go ahead
and push the button save and create
extensions and when I do that I'm gonna
be prompted to go ahead and create some
add extensions and so add extensions
allow me to add in links site links
underneath the edge just like you see
here so when you've added your sitelink
extensions and other extensions you save
it you'll be able to see your new Vout
here here we can see the ad we created
okay notice it's got the three headlines
notice it's got the two descriptions and
if I want to add it I can just click
edit add and go ahead and edit it I
don't want to edit it then I don't have
to I can always go back so you can
always edit it out after it's been
created okay if not no big deal notice
when you actually create your ad in some
cases Google's going to review it to
make sure it fits within Google's
guidelines and policies but once it's
approved you'll see it under you'll see
approved under the status column and
that's pretty much how you would go
ahead and create a text ad okay so when
it does get approved it's going to be in
the rotation with the other two ads and
so what Google's gonna do is serve up
each other you believe and then
eventually the app that is performing
best will get served up more and that
way you're putting your best ad always
in front of the user who's looking for
the product and service you're offering
so now let's talk about the metrics so
associated with these keywords these ads
these a groups and campaigns so there
are a lot of metrics in Google Ads a lot
of metrics and we're not even gonna
cover most of these metrics we're just
gonna cover what I deem the most common
the most important metrics to get you
going so if you find yourself
advertising whether that be on Google's
search network or Google's Display
Network you're gonna have some common
metrics and here are the metrics that
we're going to focus on today so you
have impressions cost clicks
average CPC conversions cost per
conversion CTR or click the array and
Quality Score so let's go through these
metrics here and talk about what they
are so impressions really it's the
number of times your ads been shown on
that particular network whether it's
Google search or display and so an
impression is just how many times
somebody actually seen you're at okay
whether they actually physically seen it
or not if your ad is showing up on that
network then an impression is gonna get
counted so here for looking at ads we
can see we have over a period of time
certain amount of impressions okay so
that's how many times this particular ad
has been shown so this particular out
here the first one at the top has been
shown five hundred fifty seven times
over this period of time which is
year-to-date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so anytime your ad gets clicked
you're going to pay Google X amount so
if I go back to Google ads I can see
what my total cost is and not only can I
see what my total cost is I can see what
my average cost per click is and so
there's a lot of factors that go into
what you actually pay and some of these
factors are who else is advertising way
you're advertising what network you're
advertising on what time of day what
particular keyword and so there's a lot
of factors and so here I can see on
average year to date I've spent a dollar
eighty per click on this particular ad
for total of thirty two dollars and 33
cents so I can really see how much I've
actually spent and so clicks is just
refers to how many times somebody
clicked on your ad so if your ads been
shown you need an impression and once
somebody sees your ad they're gonna
click on your ad so the whole idea is to
get the click remember you want to be in
positions one through three so I want to
make sure that my average position is
between one and three and so if you're
looking in Google ads at metrics and you
don't see average position well you can
always add
as it calms if I click on columns here
and then I go to competitive metrics and
I click on average position and I'm
gonna move average position all the way
to the top here so if I click move
average position all the way at the top
I'm gonna be able to see what my average
position is over that particular period
of time so here I can see I'm in
positions one through three and that's
where you want to be you want to be in
positions one through three so if you're
in positions one through three that
means you're at the top if you're on
Google search or that means you're in a
prominent position on the Display
Network so if your ad is shown meaning
this gets an impression then likely
somebody's gonna click on that ad and if
somebody clicks on that ad it's going to
generate a click which in turn is going
to generate cost and so ideally what you
want to do is you want to measure the
rate at which people click on your ad
based on how many times it was shown so
here I can see 28 clicks over three
thousand five hundred forty-nine
impressions that's a point seven nine
percent click-through rate so ideally
the higher the click-through rate the
better the app and the higher the
clicker rate the chances are you're
going to get more traffic to your site
so we want to be able to measure your
clicks and we want to be able to measure
click-through rate and we also want to
measure cost per click which is really
the total cost divided by the number of
clicks so if I go back to Google Ads
here you can see you know seventeen
dollars and fifty seven cents over
twenty eight clicks that averages out to
about 63 cents per click so that's how I
get cost per click now your class per
click is going to vary a little bit okay
so it's gonna vary based on keyword it's
gonna be based on where your advertising
will position etc so there's a lot of
factors involved with cost per click but
that's how you would actually calculate
it but Google Ads actually does a
calculation for you for collector rate
and cost per click but in case you want
to know you can always divide clicks
into cost
okay so conversions probably one of the
most important metrics you're going to
use in Google Ads because you're paying
Google and if you're paying Google for
advertising you want to make sure you're
getting return on your investment so
versions are added when a user clicks on
your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something sign up for a newsletter etc
so you want to make sure that if you're
in Google ads that you're measuring
conversions and so you simply want to go
to tools so if you go to tools and then
click on conversions you want to make
sure that you're running conversions
ideally what you want to do is you want
to run conversions from Google Analytics
but you can certainly set up conversions
within Google Ads as well
notice I also have call from ads as set
up as a conversion so you have an
opportunity in Google Ads to add a
number of different conversions and the
more conversions you add really the
better off you are because you want to
measure up all your campaigns against
conversions if I go back to campaigns I
want to be able to see what campaigns
are driving conversions and if I can
measure that and I have a campaign
that's really driving in versions that
I'm gonna continue to advertise on
Google okay so here over this particular
period of time I could see one campaign
has driven nine conversions at one
hundred and twenty eight dollars and 67
cents cost per conversion and so how do
I get cost per conversion well I get my
total cost divided by the number of
conversions and then I could see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so really if I have 241 clicks
and nine conversions that's nine divided
by 241 that's three point seven seven
percent conversion rate so I can measure
conversion rate cost per conversion and
conversion just by setting up
conversions in Google Ads
and so ideally if you're gonna pay
Google for advertising you want to be
able to measure return on investment via
conversions so again
seat cost per conversion is just really
the the total cost divided by the number
of conversions and then click the rate
again just as a reminder the total
clicks divided by the total number of
impressions and then one other metric
we're going to talk about here too
is quality scores so quality score is
really Google's way of measuring how
well your keywords are are compared to
the ad associated with it
expect to click the right and the
landing page so quality score is the
backbone of Google Ads so if I go back
to Google ads and I click on keywords
quality score is something you want to
measure and if you don't have it in your
columns you can certainly just click on
columns and add it and so here I can see
my quality score and quality score is a
measurement between 1 and 10 and so if
you have a good quality score Google's
gonna score you higher because your
keyword is relevant to your ad it's
relevant to the landing page and you
have it a good expected click-through
rate if you don't have a good quality
score Google's gonna let you know why
you don't have a good quality score so
again your three categories that make up
quality score or landing page experience
which means really Google looking at the
landing page you're sending people to
and they're seeing if the page loads
well fast does it have ads good content
is it good landing page will the end
user have a good experience they also
look at the ad relevance okay is the ad
relevant to the keyword and they'll also
look at the expect to click the rate
okay so based on other advertisers and
their click-through rate are you
achieving the same click-through rate
and so those three factors make up
Quality Score quality score is a metric
assigned to keywords so if you don't
have a good quality score you need to
fix it because the repercussion is
you're going to have to pay more so
having a good quality score likely means
you're going to pay less per click so
you want to make sure that if you've
been on a keyword that the keyword goes
to a relevant landing page the ad itself
is relevant and you're getting a good
click-through rate so quality score is
the backbone of Google ads and how it
works so you want to make sure you have
a good quality score so optimizing your
ads so what if you don't have a good
quality score what if you're not getting
conversion
well there's things you can do so
remember we want to make sure that we're
adding extensions whether that be call
site link review app add extensions to
your ads because it's going to increase
the click-through rate so you can also
really hone your ad copy if you're
selling products and you're running
promotion maybe you want to add in a
little sense of urgency to help people
you know realize hey if this this
promotions ending maybe I want to click
on the ad and take action okay with
Google ads you can always run a be
testing on ads and so what you could do
is run two ads and one ad group and see
what ad is performing best in terms of
click-through rate or conversion rate
and whatever ad is running better you
can always run that ad and then continue
more testing so that way you're always
putting your best forward in terms of
advertising in the ad copy whether that
be text or display you always want to
use call-to-action you want to get
people to click on your ad when somebody
clicks on your ad it's going to improve
click-through rate click to rate
improves quality score so as I mentioned
a several times already you want to make
sure your ads are placed at the top
between positions one and three on
Google search so you can measure ad
position in Google ads and if you're not
ranked between one and three you want to
increase your bid you can also optimize
for local search so local is an ad
extension that you can add to your ad
you can also advertise at a time when
your audience is online or you can
advertise on during business hours only
so you can adjust when you advertise on
Google ensure some of your ads you know
capitalize on some particular events
that are related to your industry so you
can capitalize on that okay you can
certainly ask Google to accelerate your
ads okay or you can do standard delivery
so Google can spread out your clicks and
show your ads throughout the day Google
search is all about keywords so you want
to be able to pick and choose the right
keywords first you can also add negative
keywords
so if you're bidding on a specific
industry let's just say you have
software and you want somebody to sign
up for your particular piece of software
but you don't offer a free trial then
maybe you want to add free as a negative
keyword so if you don't offer anything
for free free should be a negative
keyword so if somebody actually does
type in looking for free software then
your ads not gonna show up so that's the
whole idea behind negative keywords okay
you can use dynamic keyword insertion
into your ads meaning you can ask Google
hey I want to dynamically insert a
keyword into my ad that somebody uses to
make your ad more relevant so relevancy
increases click-through rate and
improves quality score so as you can see
there's a lot of things you can do
here's some more things you can use
branding keywords you can use particular
match types in Google so let's talk
about match ties for a second so you
have different match types if I go back
to Google Ads
here I could see my keywords that I'm
bidding on so by default if you actually
bid on a keyword it's gonna be broad
match and so if I've been on the keyword
medical computer if somebody typed in
something related to medical and
included the keyword medical but not
computer then my ad may show up however
I can make an exact match so somebody
can type in exactly only medical
computer so if I click Edit and I can
change the match type for that
particular keyword to exact then that
means that somebody that types an only
medical computer my hat is going to show
up I can basically do phrase match so if
somebody types in looking for something
that's going to help me with medical
computers okay that's a longtail phrase
work keyword query but the kree word
medical computer is in that order so my
hat is gonna show up okay so with phrase
match your ad is going to show when
somebody types in that keyword you're
bidding on in that order
you also have broad match modifier so if
you have a plus sign in front of the
keyword then that means that somebody
acts
has to use the keyword in the query in
order for your ad to show up okay so you
could change the match type of any
keyword so using exact or phrase then
chances are you're going to have lower
volume of queries but probably higher
relevancy if you use a broad match then
your ad could show up for any
combination of search queries so you
really want to be careful on the match
type that you choose so keep an eye on
quality score remember Google has
quality score between 1 and 10 the
higher quality score the better you are
so really if you have a quality score I
would say anything below 4 you probably
want to pause the keyword okay so you
can measure quality score at the keyword
level so if I go back to Google ads and
I have keywords that are say 3 chances
are I'm going to have to pay more for
the click and it might not be worth it
so I may want to end up pausing that
keyword and try other keywords that are
more relevant that I can send traffic to
a more Rowen landing page or I can have
an ad that's more relevant to that
keyword in order to help with the
quality score okay you can ensure that
your landing pages are mobile-friendly
so that's another thing you want to keep
in mind that most people start their
search on mobile so you certainly want
to make sure that your landing pages are
optimized because if somebody starts to
search on mobile likes your products or
service chances are they're coming back
via desktop or even going into the store
most searches start on mobile so you
want to make sure those pages are
optimized and there's plenty more things
you can do to optimize your ads you want
to make sure you group and organize your
keywords into relevant ad groups why
because you can write relevant ads for
those keywords so if I go back to Google
Ads
I want to make sure if I go to ad groups
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another
so what's my a group name well if it's
medical PC if I click on medical PC I
want to make sure the keywords in that a
group are all relative to medical piece
see I want to structure my campaigns and
ad groups to target more ads effectively
so you want to be able to you know
organize your campaigns and ad groups
and the rule of thumb here is you should
organize your campaigns and ad groups
based on the site architecture of your
site so the way your website is laid out
in the navigation is how you should
likely structure your campaigns and ad
groups focus on your budget okay so you
want to put more budget to campaigns
that are converting okay you can use
automatic bidding for ads to maximize
results so meaning that google has what
they call artificial intelligence so
Google can do a lot of the bidding and a
lot of the managing for you that's
really a great benefit to running your
ads on Google so their machines are
learning behavior from your keywords
that you're bidding on and so ideally
when they learn what's converting
they're going to bid more and try and
help you get the conversion for the
keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that Google Ads has to offer owner to
improve performance so there's a lot of
things you can do on Google ads this was
simply a overview of Google ads so you
have a lot of different options
available from ad formats to where you
can advertise to all the different
metrics you can do is to measure
performance to all the things you can do
to optimize the account so if you guys
have anything you want to add by all
means please feel free to do so in the
comment section below the video we're
certainly gonna have more more
information more webinars on Google Ads
specifically targeting specific topics
in Google ads so look forward to that
and I want to thank you for joining if
you have more information please you can
visit our YouTube channel simply learn
or you can go to our website it's simply
learn com for more information thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here